pour sylvie genevoix né à
châteauneuf-sur-loire en 1944 morte à
paris en 2012
c'est une journée mémorable une victoire
posthume
la fille de maurice genevoix été en
première ligne pour défendre la mémoire
et l'oeuvre littéraire de son père elle
s'est battue de toutes ses forces pour
que l'auteur de ceux de 14 entre au
panthéon
après le fracas des armes maurice
genevoix a fait de la vie une autre
la vie c'est pas une blague c'est pas
une fille chaise c'est pas un combat
quotidien c'est pas une espèce de de
harcèlement n'est ce pas qui en effet
qui rend nos contemporains haletant mais
c'est une chose qui à partir de chaque
matinée de chaque réveil le seul fait de
sentir vivant de respirer et de vivre et
bien c'est cet admirable
après la disparition de singly genevois
c'est son épouse qui reprend le flambeau
est désormais ses deux petits fils de
maurice genevoix le porte drapeau de ce
combat le président de la république a
su trouver dans maurice genevoix dans
l'écriture de maurice genevoix dans son
oeuvre à la fois ce grand témoignage et
puis en même temps une forme de
sensibilité à quelque chose qui peut
être dépasse un peu l'homme qui est
cette question qui est très présente
dans son oeuvre qui à là question
d'équilibré en fait entre l'homme et la
nature
et je crois que c'est cet ensemble de
raisons qui font qu'un président de la
république même jeune peut tenter une
j'aimerais genevois mais ça supposait
d'abord effectivement de l'avoir lu
il ne restait plus qu'une pâle à
l'académicien ce sera le pontet ans pour
l'éternité
[Musique]